نواف عزيز الان ينضم الينا مره اخرى من
الرياض نواف
اتابع معك ايضا لفظ ده والفرحه من قبل
الجماهير ويترك المايكروفون تفضل
ت الجماهير هنا في شوارع الرياض تحتفل
بهذا الفوز الكبير الذي حققه المنتخب
السعودي الذي بدا بروح منافسه عاليه في
هذه المباراه التي خالفت جميع التوقعات
كما نشاهد الان ااه الاحتفالات في الشوارع
التي اا بعد انتهاء المباراه بنحو ساعه لا
تزالت لا تزال الفرحه تعم الشوارع هنا
والفرح بالمنتخب السعودي الذي حقق فوز
كبير وغير متوقع والذي كان الدافع الاول
له همم وفقا لما يقوله الجماهير المشاهدين
للمباراه هنا بان استقبال ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان للاعبي المنتخب قبل
التوجه الى قطر
وتوجيه لهم عبارات العبوا واستمتعوا انا
اتوقع النتائج كبيره امامكم منافسه كبيره
جميع هذه العبارات ساهمت بتفوق المنتخب
خلال همم مباراه مع الارجنتين التي يلعب
فيها ميسي والذي كانت تخوف الاكبر منه
ناخذ راي بعض الجماهير المتواجدين الان عن
توقعات
بهذا الفوز مع الان اهلا وسهلا بك متوقع
الفوز هذا ايه والله توقعنا معكم اخوكم من
اليمن نبارك ونهني للشعب السعودي بمناسبه
فوزه فقد افرح المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وقد افرح الدول العربيه كامل فنه المنتخب
السعودي شكرا لك مشجع ايضا اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف تابعه المباراه هلا باشجع السعوديه من
قلبي وهم فخر العرب وهما صورهم حاجه كبيره
للعالم كله يحيا العرب يا تحيا السعوديه
شكرا اذا كما تشاهد خالد هذه المشاعر همم
النابعه من الفرحه التي تمت من هذا المكان
من شاشه عملاقه وفرتها امانه منطقه الرياض
اتاحت للج- ال- ال- المشاهده المباراه
المنتخب السعودي للجميع والاستمتاع بالفوز
الغير متوقع في هذا اليوم المختلف نعم
مراسل العربيه فهد
الفوز التاريخي على مستوى كاس العالم كم
تشاهد الجمهور لازال هناك
يحتفلون في ساحه ملعب لوسيل يرددون
الاهازيج
ويحتفلون ويحقق لهم اا يعني قطعه في
الكيلومترات من جميع انحاء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا الشيء همم انعكس
ولاحظنا على ايضا اللاعب السعودي كان عنده
حماس منقطع نظيره امام افضل لعيبه العالم
موجودين امام المنتخب الارجنتيني منعكس
على المباراه وقلب النتيجه التاريخيه على
المنتخب الارجنتين اثنين واحد احتفالات
كبيره ملعب
لم
يغادره اي مشجع السعودي حتى الان اكيد
بيحتفلوا ان همم حتى اذان المغرب ثم
التوجه الى احتفال في البيت السعودي اكيد
والاماكن همم الجمهور مثل السوق واقف
مناطق الجميع راح تكون احتفالات مطوله حتى
ساعات متاخره من الليل همم شاهدت يعني
شخصيات كبيره لعيبه قدامه حظروا ايضا رئيس
استاد بن نافل للرئيس فهد رئيس فهد الشعله
لعيبه قدامه خميس الزهراني محسن الحارثي
سعد مبارك لعيبه كبار حضر وايضا لمشتابعه
المنتخب السعودي واكيد انه كانوا فرحانين
مثل ما فرح الشعب السعودي ككل وايضا
الجمهور العربي اللي ساند المنتخب السعودي
ولم يخيب ظنه الاخضر كالعاده حقق فوز جميل
فوز ان شاء الله يطرز بفوز اخر حتى او
يدعم بفوز اخر حتى نضمن ان شاء الله
التاهل المستحق باذن الله تعالى الى الدور
16 برفقه اي منتخب يرافق المنتخب السعودي
سواء المكسيك او الارجنتين او بولندا
طيب نواف ارجع لك
اذا انت تتابع كذلك الاستاذ بعد الفوز من
قبل الجماهير
غير متوقعه لهذا الفوز الا انها جاءت منذ
الصباح حقيقه كنا متواجدين منذ الصباح
الباكر وجدنا الجماهير بدات تتواجد هنا في
الاماكن العامه لمشاهده المباراه على
الرغم من التوقعات التي تطلب التعادل على
الاقل ولكن الفوز كان من نصيب المنتخب
السعودي سنرصد الان الاحتفالات في الشارع
واحتفالات الماره في همم فوز المنتخب
السعودي الذي حقق فوز كبير الفرحه هنا في
كل مكان الاعلام على السيارات التي تمر
بالشوارع هنا ايضا ازدحام في الحركه
المروريه همم بسبب الاعداد الكبيره
المتوافذه الى الاماكن العامه للاحتفال
بفوز المنتخب السعودي همم اضافه الى وجود
جديد من المناطق الاخرى التي تتوفر سواء
من وزاره الرياضه او حتى من همم الهيئه
العامه الترفيه التي وفرت منطقه داخل
استاد ملعب مرسول بارك
للتشجيع
ومشاهده مباريات المنتخب السعودي خلال همم
المنافسات اضافه الى توفير همم العديد من
المناطق الاخرى في الاماكن العامه الجميع
هنا متحمس ومتفاعل مع فوز المنتخب على
الرغم من اداء الطلبه لاختبارات النهائيه
او الاختبارات الفصليه الا ان الفرحه
وصلخات الجماهير ضغطت على همم هذا الحدث
بفوز المنتخب السعودي
وتحقيق الفوز على الارجنتين الذي حتى
الجماهير العربيه خالد تحدثنا مع قبل اللي
هو كانوا يتحدثون بانهم لم يتوقعوا هذا
الفوز على منتخب قوي ومعروف ويحقق دائما
الفوز اا على الارجنتين ولكن ربما تكون
السنوات الماضيه استراتيجيه وزاره الرياضه
دعم الكبير للقطاع الرياضي حقق هذا التقدم
تطور اللاعبين تحفيز الامير محمد بن سلمان
لاعبين المنتخب قبل الانتقال والتوجه الى
قطر للعب في منافسات المونديال كانت هي
الدافع الاول نتوقع ايضا خالد ان يتوافق
جماهير اكبر الى قطر تتوجه لدعم المنتخب
همم حقيقه بعدها هذا الفوز الكبير خاصه
وان اجراءات همم السفر الى قطر مسهله
كثيرا لجميع الجماهير مشاعر جميله نشهدها
هنا في الرياض واح طلعت من الجميع
المواطنين والمقيمين يفرحون بهذا الفوز
كونه يشكل فوز او انتصار عربي لمنتخب عربي
وهو المنتخب السعودي الذي حقق هذا الفوز
اليوم نعم
طيب شكرا لك
خبر
عبد الرحمن مبروك عبد الرحمن
يعني كنت قريب ربما من المناطق اللي اللي
توجه فيها الجمهور السعودي لمتابعه همم
اول مره اعتقد انه انت كنت يمكن تشترك مع
الكثير من انه همم مش عدم تفاؤل لكن
الواقعيه يعني في المباراه كيف شفت متابعه
المباراه وكيف ترصد لنا الاجواء
صحيح انا كنت متفائل بحذر خالد فعلا لكن
المنتخب السعودي اليوم قدم مباراه عظيمه
للغايه كنت قبل قليل في القبه في مدينه
الخبر في اكثر من 700
شاب وشابه حضر المباراه اجواء احتفاليه
تشبه لحد كبير خالد اجواء مونديال عام 94
عندما فاز منتخب السعودي على المغرب وعلى
بلجيكا بهدف سعيد العوران اليوم كل المدن
السعوديه تقول قولوا يلا يلا خذوا الفنايل
قولوا يلا وسووا الهوايل اجواء رائعه
واحتفاليه سنخوض خالد معكم غمار همم
الاحتفالات
ونشاهد همم الفرحه الكبيره همم الجميع خرج
بالسيارات حاملين الاعلام والفرحه على
ملامحهم كمان نشاهد شباب وشباب اطفال
وكبار كلهم خرجوا الى شوارع مدينه الخبر
للاحتفال بفوز المنتخب السعودي على
المنتخب الارجنتيني طبعا سقف توقعات لدى
المنتخب السعودي والجماهير السعوديه ارتفع
خالد للغايه والاله مطالبات بان يفوز
وايضا على منتخب بولندا والمنتخب المكسيك
ويحقق العلامه الكامله لكن الجمهور الان
كما نشاهد هذه الطفله المحتله بفوز
المنتخب السعودي برفقه والدتها نشاهد ايضا
يعني من جميع الفئات العمريه خالد نساء
ورجال شباب واطفال كلهم خرجوا انا خالد
عام 94 كان عمري ثمان سنوات واذكر جيدا
عندما تاهل المنتخب السعودي للدور الثاني
كلنا خرجنا الى الشوارع مثل هذه
الاحتفالات كانت موجوده ف- تقريبا حوالي
28 سنه ونحن ننتظر مثل هذه الفرحه والان
جاءت شاب السعودي والجماهير السعوديه
متعطشه للغايه لمثل هذا الانتصار خاصه انا
المنتخب السعودي قدم تصفيات رائعه وتصدر
مجموعته قويه وكان التي كان فيها منتخب
استرالي والياباني في اليوم الناس كلها
محتفله يا خالد وفرحانه ومبسوطه
وايضا راينا فيديوهات لوزير الرياضه ورئيس
الاتحاد السعودي لكره القدم مع اللاعبين
داخل غرفه الملابس وكانوا محتفلين ويرقصون
وفرحانين فاليوم همم الكلمه كلها للشعب
السعودي حتى مواقعه التواصل خالد تويتر
منتخب السعودي على كافه مستويات العالم
نشاهد الان هنا احد الجماهير نزل من
سيارته مبروك الله يبارك في عمرك ايش رايك
في المنتخب السعودي اليوم
وكل شيء سووا المستحيل ما احد كان يتوقع
هذا الشيء ارفع رؤوسنا نفوز على نفسك
ان الله قالها نفوز فزنا على اقوى فزنا
على المرشح الاول 34 مباراه متتاليه بدون
خساره فكيف اجل المكسيك نفوز نقدر ان شاء
الله
كبير صراحه يعني 180 درجه قبل المباراه
وبعد المباراه وان شاء الله يتممها على
خير ويقدم منتخب السعودي مستويات افضل
واكبر ان شاء الله خلال مباريات القادمه
همم ما ادري اذا كان في جديد جميل نواف
نواف عزيز يتابعنا او هاني السياره خلينا
نشوف جده بعد الفوز هاني مبروك
[موسيقى]
هلا والله مبروك على الجميع وجده مختلفه
وغير جده غير من ناحيتين ناحيه انهم كانوا
فعلا نسبه التفاؤل عاليه كانوا نسبه
التحليل بنسبه للجماهير اللي نزلناها قبل
المباراه فعلا متوقعه وعاليه لانهم تحدثوا
عن نقطتين مهمتين يعني الاغلب انهم اجمعوا
على انه المنتخب السعودي اذا برز في
اللياقه العاليه واللعبه السريع راح يحصل
على نتيجه جيده ولو ربما نتيجه تاريخيه
وهو حصل على النتيجه المطلوبه رغم انه كان
هناك اس تي اي برضه من بعض اثناء المباراه
من بعض الجماهير في جده حول بعض اللاعبين
ضياعهم الفرص وهذه الفرص قد تكون او قد او
المفترض ان تكون نتيجه تاريخيه بالنسبه
للمنتخب الارجنتيني عموما في شارع
الكورنيش او امام واجهه الكورنيش الفرحه
بين المركبات وايضا اثناء خروج الان
خرج من المقاهي للي وفرتها امانه محافظه
جده او حتى ايضا المناطق المخصصه للمناطق
المشجعين لان هذه المنطقه او هذا الطريق
هو الابرز ونشاهد الفعاليه اهالي جده
واحتفالهم بفوز المنتخب السعودي طبعا
الحديث بالنسبه
لاهالي جده وحديثهم عن هذا الفوز هو طبعا
هو ليس كما ذكرت انه كان غير متوقع او
كانوا غير متفائلين ولكن هي فرحه تعبر
ايضا عن زعل لانه معظمهم خرج وقال المفروض
النتيجه تصير ثلاثه واربعه علشان كده
تحدثنا انه موضوع جدا غير ولكن راح اسال
سؤال سريع مساكم الله بالخير مساكم الف
مبروك جميعا ولكن باسال ال- الابن قبل
توقعت انك يعني اهل جده كان عندهم تفائل
كبير صراحه
توقعت اني لما تكون يعني النتيجه تعادل
يعني هل توقعتك خساره يعني مثلا اقوى شيء
تتوقع انها صراحه التعادل
كان هذا نسبه عاليه من اتفاق نسبه عاليه
عساكم على القوه
التقينا باحد الجماهير ما اب ما ابنه
واستمرار عمليه سماء الاغاني همم المنتخب
واغاني الوطنيه وكذلك مع بعض الرقصات
وايضا مع التشجيع له سواء للمواطنين وكذلك
المقيمين اللي يحتفلون اليوم في طريق
الكورنيش ما نزلنا انا الان برصد هذه
الفرحه
في على طريقه
قويه والله يوفقهم ويسدد رميهم في كل مكان
وفي كل زمان والله يا اخي ما اقدر فرحه ما
اقدر اوصلها
اليوم طبعا المنتخب السعودي
هذا كله اللي صار بالاجتماع اللي قام به
سمو سيدي ولي العهد مع اللعيبه كلامك كان
جميل جدا جدا الله يعطيها الصحه والعافيه
ويقويه على امور هذه والله انه مبسوطين
فيه واني
شعور ما اقدر شعور والله ما اقدر امين يا
رب ننتقل لك يا خالد و بينما نلتقط هذه
اللقطات من همم طريق الكورنيش في مدينه
جده طيب احنا رجالك بكل سهوله اكيد اذهب
مره اخرى هذه المره مع عبد المحسن الحربي
المفدى العربيه ايضا بارك لك عبد المحسن
همم
ناس ايضا متابعين لهذه المباراه في
مونديال كاس العالم كيف كانت
تاثير نتيجه هذه المباراه بفوز المنتخب
السعودي على المنتخب الاردني
نعم مع خالد دانيه يحدث البدايه عن اجواء
ما قبل المباراه كان الجمهور السعودي في
كل شارع في الدوحه حتى بدات المباراه
وانقلب الحال الى ان يتواجد الجمهور
السعودي في كل مكان
ليحتفل الجمهور السعودي اصبح محط الانظار
القنوات العالميه وسائل الاعلاميه اصبح
حتى تدفق الجمهور السعودي في كل مكان بعد
هذه النتيجه لتسالهم وتلتقي بهم بعد
الانتصار الكبير الذي حققه المنتخب
السعودي على المنتخب الارجنتيني في
الحقيقه تواجد الان خالد في الركن السعودي
هنا حيث بدات الاحتفالات بعد فوز المنتخب
السعودي وانتقلت الى هنا حيث الركن
السعودي بعض الجماهير همم
استطاعت ان تصل الى هذا المكان بشكل سريع
همم تحتفل في الركن السعودي الذي هو همم
منطقه منظمه من قبل السعوديه بشكل كامل
استضافه يوم الامس عدد كبير من الجماهير
تحتوي على شاشه ومناطق لفعاليات ومطاعم
ومناطق ترفيهيه اخرى هنالك العديد من
الفعاليات المختلفه التي تقام على همم
هامش او في هذا الركن السعودي اليوم الركن
السعودي والوجه الابرز لكل همم المشجعين
السعوديين وغيرهم شهاده العديد من همم
المشجعين الاخرين الذين قدموا الى من
مشجعين منتخبات الاخرى وحتى من الجنسيات
الاخرى الذين قدمه الى الركن السعودي
لمشاركه الجمهور السعودي الاحتفالات هنالك
ايضا كما تشاهد بالصوره جمهور قطري يشارك
الجمهور السعوديه الفرحه ايضا وسائل
الاعلام الدوليه توجهت مباشره الى هذا
الركن السعودي نهايه المباراه متوقعه ان
تزيد العدد خلال المساء همم في هذا الركن
الذي ليس فقط هو مخصص لمباريات المنتخب
السعودي ولكن يعرض كل المباريات ويستهدف
كافه همم الشرائح من مشجعين المنتخبات
الاخرى اذا خالد نتيجه كبيره عريضه لم يكن
احد يتوقعها لان سقف التوقعات ارتفع بشكل
كبير جدا بعد هذه همم النتيجه الكل يترقب
المباراه الثانيه ولكن هم يحتفلون الان في
هذه المباراه في الحقيقه همم الجمهور
السعودي خالد هو حاله شكل في الدوحه على
همم
دخلت وانا اشاهد هذه الحاله امامي حيث عدد
كبير جدا من الجمهور السعودي ربما يشكل
الجمهور اكبر لمنتخب منتخب من المنتخبات
المشاركه في هذا همم المونديال وهو متواجد
ومشارك بفعاليه كبيره جدا في كافه المناطق
ليست في الركن السعودي فقط انما همم في
المناطق الترفيهيه الاخرى همم دي الدوحه
سواء كان سوق واقف او المناطق الاخرى لذلك
يشكل جمهور السعودي همم منطقه او عامل
جانب لكل همم المناطق الاخرى في الدوحه
ايضا يساهم بشكل كبير في نجاح هذه البطوله
جماهيريه تحدث عن حضور الجماهيري اليوم في
استاد الوسيل وهو يحتفظ 80,000 متفرج على
الجمهور السعودي حاضر بكل قوه خارقه